hello hello my name is Ella and I come
from Croatia my question is in regards
to this even talking to theory about Big
Bang whether you agree with it or not
thanks bye so I hide Ella you're asking
whether I agree with Stephen Hawking's
theory of the Big Bang well Stephen has
been working on the details of the how
it actually works out and so I can't
really argue with his question about the
details but I can tell you that
astronomers have known about the Big
Bang since 1929 and it was predicted
even before that mathematically so it
was discovered in 1929 by Edwin Hubble
who discovered that distant galaxies are
going away from us with immense speeds
that are proportional to the distance so
that discovery back in 1929 told us
immediately that something very amazing
happened at the beginning of time and
we've been thinking about it and working
out the details ever since so there's
pretty solid understanding that the Big
Bang really did happen and now the
question is how did it happen so we're
waiting for Stephen Hawking and other
people like him to help us work out
those details